hello and welcome now i'd like to show
you
how you can easily calculate a k-means
classed analysis
online with data tab to do this please
visit datatep.net
and click on the statistics calculator
in order to calculate a class analysis
you simply choose the tab cluster
if you want to use your own data you can
clear the table
and then copy your own data into this
table
i will simply use the example data now
so i want to calculate
a k means class analysis let's say we
want to cluster a group
of people by salary and age
first we can define the number of
clusters and we enter the number of
clusters
datadeb will now calculate everything
for you
and you get your results right away so
here you can see the three clusters with
the centroids
and there you can see the elbow method
in this case
the results indicate that we should use
a solution with two clusters
we have selected three clusters before
so we can change it
in order to get the best suitable number
of clusters
but let's go through the results now
step by step
here we can see how many elements are
assigned to the different clusters
and here we get the plot with the
different clusters
here we can see one cluster we see one
cluster there
and we see another cluster here further
we get a table
where each element is allocated to a
cluster
if we now choose 2 as the number of
clusters
we get new results and we can see them
here
in this plot we have one cluster here
and one cluster there moreover we can
see that
the two clusters fit the data quite well
thank you for listening
i